Welcome to the first Project Kamp update video!
So, these videos are basically just to keep
progress of what we're doing.
To make sure wearchive it for ourselves.
And also, for our family and friends to follow.
We basicallybought this big piece of land in Portugal!
We're going to transform it into something,
to live and work in a more sustainable way.
We don't really know where this is going...
We havesome sort of wild plans in our head.
But, I guess that this is just to keep following that process.
So, ifyou're interested, make sure to subscribe!
If not, yeah, don't...
Overall, the videos are going to be veryquick and rough.
Because, we just want to make sure we actually
do document it, and don't forgetabout it...
So, if you make it too complex,
I know we're not gonna do it in the end.
We justhave very little people around here,
so we need to use our resources properly.
So, yeah: first update!
Let me give you a quick tour of the land!
We're now walking down onthe land, so this is all the land!
Above there as well actually, but there's
a bit less interesting things to show for now.
This road is going down to the workspace,and the kitchen.
We're first gonna have a look at the workspace,
which is a bit hiddenin the bushes around here on the left...
Yes, so, we can go in here...
A very good pathway...
So, here's the building.
The workspace was all burned down,
during a fire a few years ago.
So, the roof is pretty broken,
and slowly the trees are taking over...
It's a pretty big space to all the way down
there
Some concrete structure?
I don't know how strong or solid it is...
I guess we haveto test?
It looks like there's some work to do.
So, yeah, that's the current workspace,
butwe can go in as well!
Because, yesterday, I made a little pathway,
which is kindof fun and there's a lot of overgrown bushes...
It's mainly thorns, so you really have to make yourway in...
It could be fun to get in.
Here's the front side of the workspace,
so we made a hole there.
Well, the hole was already there...
We just cleaned it.
And then, here,through the thorns, I made a bit of a path.
Oh yeah, and the camera sometimeshas a bit of focusing issues...
Okay, so, right there is another entrance.
So, yeah, as you can see,
it's fully overgrown, but this is the structure.
Here is another part.
I don't think it everhad a roof,
but it does have a foundation there.
So, I think that the ideal scenario right now
is that this is all just workspace.
And then, here is the roof.
I guess I need to watchout
that those things don't fall on my head.
It should be okay?
We'll do it likethis.
At least, we then have it on camera!
Which could be a cool shot!
Maybe nexttime.
And then, here's our little hole out.
So, yeah, that's the workspace!
There's still some work to do.
I think this could be a very cool place, because...
Down there--
Well, you don't really see it now...
You have somewhat, and you could have, a nice view!
So, now, we go up to the other structure,
whichis going to be the kitchen.
We go up here through bushes.
These are basicallythe two existing structures on the land.
And, I would say they're not very well built...
So, we have to see if we canrenovate them,
or we have to rebuild them.
That could be the kitchen.
Also, a lot ofthorns here.
We also made a pathway right here.
And, as you can see, underneath there's really ruins.
So, they've been built like over 50 yearsago,
and this is more built on top later.
But, underneath, it could be a super coolplace to store food.
Because of the thick rocks and the granite,
it keeps everything very cool
I mean, it could use some cleaning up, but...
There's another area here.
It looks lighter on the camera!
That's the downstairs.
And then, the top I actually never entered!
Evenbefore we bought it, because you just couldn't get in...
Or, at least not quickly, when with the people there.
So, I started making a pathway to there as well.
Right here, in the forest.
It's notreally a forest, but more like a starting forest.
A lot of this burnt down a few yearsago with a big fire,
so that's why you see alot of young trees now.
There's actually a lotof acacia trees, which grow super fast!
But, in a way, they also kind of dominate all the other trees...
So, in a way, it's cool that they're there,
but maybe for the long term, not really...
But, we still need to learn more about that.
I was quite surprised, when going intothis kitchen.
Because, I mean, it's also a very rough building.
It's almost falling apart.
But, this actually could be very nice, I think.
I don't know what this flap is.
Some insulation material put into the wall?
I don't know.
Yeah, so, here could be anice way to cook.
So, imagine!
Imagine that over here you have a little kitchen.
Something in the fridge...
Yeah, come for food!
It could be nice to cook here.
And then, what I like aboutthis is this window here,
because it really gives you an overview of the land.
Where you could growyour vegetables,
which I think is a nice addition.
Yeah, so, that was the kitchenstructure.
It's still not the shot...
Let's see now--
Oops, sorry! The card was full!
Now, we're going back from thekitchen.
Towards, uh...
Just to show you the end of the land.
Yeah, like I said, very bushy...
All right.
So, I'll have a walk on here,
but maybe i'll just take a run!
So, yeah, this is the bottom.
There'sthe kitchen.
It's quite a big piece of land.
That's, I guess, the downside of a big land.
Youneed to run around a lot, to go from A to B.
Currently, we are parked down here, at thebottom
So, basically, everything here is the land.
Hello!
That's the neighbor.
Portuguese, but noEnglish.
I still need to turn some Portuguese.
So, that's currently the house.
And yeah, this is the bottom of the land,
but i realized actually forgot a few things.
But, maybe I could just--
Over here, we have anelectricity pole.
I mean, it was already there to provide the neighbors more electricity
We would need to get it at some point as well.
But, I figured: ''You can climb in therea bit,
and you might have a better view."
It's getting a bit narrow for the shoes, so I'll stop here.
You can see a little bit of the surroundings.
Overall, it's very green.
Maybe next time, we will go higher.
All right! Let's go to another thing!
Thisarea at the end is probably where we're going to
set up the Basekamp in thebeginning, because it's kind of flat.
It's protected, so this means the two
shipping containers would come here.
You can see more about that in the nexttime.
Well, one thing I wanted to show you...
The neighbors were actually saying thereused
to be a well, up here in the bushes.
It had enough water all year round,
toprovide the land with water, which is kind of cool to have.
But, we also never saw that one before,
because it was just covered in bushes.
So, yeah, I did some chopping and some walking in the bushes.
Then, I made a pathway, and I'm just looking where I was.
All right, sorry...
I had to turn off my camerafor a bit,
because i got a bit confused...
This whole bush here, which was
an upcoming forest, was chopped down.
So, I was calling a bit, to find out why.
It looks pretty rough.
This wasn'there like yesterday, but apparently someone
in the neighborhood chops down trees here for hisfirewood?
I wasn't really aware of that!
It looks pretty rough!
I mean, it kind of changes the landscape...
But, I guess we need to work out a little bit of
these things as well withthe neighborhood, here on the land.
Anyway, let's have a look at the water.
I guess I now also lost my pathway somewhere here?
But, it doesn't have that many thorns.
So, maybe, we can just go in here?
There's alsoa lot of mushrooms in here, at this moment.
I still need to learn which oneyou can eat, here in Portugal.
And, then somewhere...
I think it's there!
So, here's the water!
Let me take a better shot...
Sorry for the sound effects.
So,here's quite a big reservoir of water.
It's a bit covered between all the otherthings.
Let me throw a stick.
Yeah, water...
It just need some cleaningup, before we can even access it.
All right!
So, that was it!
The first Project Kampupdate video!
If you want to see more Project Kamp videos,
make sure to visit our academy!
If you want to continue to follow this process,
and see what we're going to do with the land...
Makesure to subscribe!
There are a lot of videos and updates coming up,
to see how we regeneratethe land.
And, how we set up our infrastructure.
If you want to help out in some way,
make sure to visit support.projectkamp.com.
To see how you can help out at this moment!
Thanks for watching, and see you in the next video!